[音楽]
時はさかのぼり
今から4年前
皆さん
2014年の youtube 覚えてますか
本日はまず社長ですあの四年前なんですけども
うーむのメンバーでバービー消したんですよ
を得てますか4年前の有無
目が今すごいルームです沢山今生むてすごいたくさんクリエイターさんといるんです
けども
4年前ってもうほんと数えるくらいしかユーチューバーがいなかったんですけど
4年前北バービッキーを実はしたんですよみんなで処女年前に集まったうん部の初期
メンのみんなで今日は
バーベキューすることになりましたって
ちょっとこの youtube この4年ですごい変わったじゃないですか
ルール変わったし変わらないこともあると思うんですけどもちょっとねこの
4年経って
ウールのスーツ名の皆さんは某立ってるのかちょっと気になるなと思ってちょ
皆さんの話とか聞いていこうと思いますうん
ブーブ初期メンバーの皆様お久し目で
8年ぶりに再集結ということで
なんか
偶然かいろいろあったと思うんですけど楽しく話しあげればいいなと思います
元バーン
me
自民者ちょうどほぼ初めて会った時だったんだよねあれ
初めてだとか私はほとんどあった本ないくらいで身長はターゲットか動画で言ってて
たぶん1回2回しか会ったことないんださっき見てきたんだよ年前だぞ
一応しっかりしてるねちょっとすごいねしたらなんか想像以上に身長が高くてびっくり
した目だよ
ことでしたから動画の結構控えて味は値段でが弾でちょっとおとなしく待ったんじゃ
ないよ再掲
いや僕もうとらしくなりますけどね外れ君もなぜメタルでも規模が大きくなったね
注文でいろいろ学んでいっぱれ
波多津色々あっはいいろいろありましたね名いろいろ俺も4粒は彼はされたおっだって
俺だってあったし
よそうなすごい気持ちがわかって朝か
ねあの集まる直前クライネ集まる前ぐらいで4年前のアドラー市に良いですねハッハー
アゾ飾ったとか色々
tb ベンツ e 330ザッハー
みんなちゃんの貸せないと味
入っておき笑じゃあ追い詰められた感じで言ったら没
ここずエロ t 狙ってないよちーさんこの
年間って何か変わったことがありました変わったこと
あったことなんか別特に変わってはいないわけない
なんか別に気持ちは変わってないよねあーんとれ素直な心は小学生が亡くなっており
ますそこ
なんてがは変わらないけどまぁでもなんか周りの環境は変わったかな
感謝しますねください
ねユーチューバーとしての立ち位置という大きな4つでそういう大きくなったし事務所
もね
ロン前と比べたらん
すごく大きくかな
あっはずです逃げる形ですね
ね
いや長いよね音順だったりとかではない
なんかというか
すっごいなかったねー
年ですもんね男
4年間の中で親分の中で
一番変わったなあと思うこと苦難でしたもう
あったってことですよね
凄い難しい質問が動く
ブーブーチューバードゥダれたことですねパリィパコで結構なんだ4年間ん
みんなあーカーロスられてるって言うところかアンヌ flat 4てロス鯉
ん
なんかいや止めるユーチューバーさんもいますの悠々
それでもみんなそのユーチューバーでいるっていう
入れたっていう変わらないけどそのためにみんなすげー実は細かいところでいろんな
ことを
変わってる
感じがしてますね僕もそうですねだからあの
やっぱユーチューバーでいるっていう変わらないために編集を変えたり
やることを変えたりして変化したから今も変わらずに入れるかなっていう
感じでなんかよく昔の肇社長のが良かったなーとか阿南あるじゃんで
で変わっちまったかぴぱら空ジャムでも変わってなかったらたぶん今もう
ユーチューバーでいるかわかんないかと言うなね楽しくない人も同じ事しててもそう
変えていかないとやっぱりいろんな人も出てくるし
うっちゃいいこと言いますね頑張りましょうウィッチていくという
今後さんの鳥だとか1ならダウン
退化してたよなぁ
ありません
4年間は今はとーございましたがあったぞ
これね色んな経験をしたいろんな技戦でも肇社長の色目消したよまあまあ良く回れそう
あのね色んな決して大人になったねそうあの海底のことでへこたれなくなっあああ
ああああああ
だからそういう意味でマジでポジティブな方向で
いい経験したなって思います奏曲が阿部バロー開かれてる皆さんにはーいよ伝えるため
なんですよねあなたの愛は何ですか
てよ愛の定義を抜いてくださあ私は言わはい
自分が楽しむことですあーーー事故いですしこいで白スカはじめ
うーんわっ
ブーブー日本で打っなパティニョ
z さんから連絡が来ていん
使うとされてそうでね原宿でかまだなひどいシーンだよねうん実山のあの連だけで逃げ
座るどっからかじゃあ
イギリスのいます四白それじゃあ今で撮ってよチョコ a
なんか昔よりも認知されてるし
あのにぎやかになるもうちょっとさあ何か
まぁ一応あるけどオタクみたいな感じもあったじゃないありませんだかちょっと地味な
感じで何やってんのーみたいな感じが
最近この4年間でもう第二生き物とかができる
昔だったら戻りませたんですけどあ延長しますのそうだよねだからなんかね初めての
動画見てるとなんか
まあ一致最もお金で炎上しているとかもう何か昔から見てると
まあ化していうことなのかなあもう
思うくらいそうそうだからそれだけみんな年度比
影響力があるということだねに見えるチームは音ですね
までも再集結自体は良いキャンベルよねーよねや最終月には眠れ人気でした
ん
ジェクセスすべきです
i から僕はおもちゃ玩具レビュー1本でと
学校4年間で変わったことがありました4年間で変わったこと
意外とないからやってる作品が僕は玩具レビューなんで
ひたすら玩具をレビューしている
動画をアップしてるから
相も変わらず全然変わってるんでたしぶりに会っても何かすぐあの時の空間にも取れ
るっていう
たいと朝日さん的に一番変わっただと思ってたんですだな
私自身ならしていうか完全に女性ユーチューバーですねすごいたシャビますよねー
立って京都毬恵さん私ですだけじゃんあ確かにあの時もつけなかったぞ
会でも基礎の女性宇宙ば増えたのは多分浅井さんは鮮度を切って
イヤー道は書いてましたから色なんだろうねぇ
ず皆さんしたの時にこの4年間で何か買わなかったことがありますかですよ
この今日集まってい
最終月した初期メンバーはやっぱり今で
線と体が張ってあります
頑張ってますねみんな
it だけ皆さん打ち勝つですかおいしかっ分
あああああちゃ
って今回通してバーベキューをしたかと言いますと
えっ面部風呂って奴いそういうゲームがきっかけでございます
なんと2月の22日にウェーブフロンティア2がリリースされる
モーグリブルンってや2のテーマが再集結
はいこれ
ルールが入っいうわけで今回グーグルの初期見えるのはみんなで再集結してみました
ブレイブフロンティア2なんですけども前作ブレイブフロンティア
ポンすごいねやってますって何て言ってくると思ったわ
設定すごい品もやり込んだりすることもそれがさらにパワーアップして帰ってきたと
いうことで本作も売って楽しんでみようかなと思っております
そしてなんと今回
別のプレゼントがございますうぇい
この動画を見てブレイブフロンティアつをプレイしてくれた方から抽選で3名様に
この
初期メン全員のサインの快地グンマーからプレゼントへ
[拍手]
ブーバーしこの再集結パーカーぬーんっすよ
ゲーム内にある応募フォームから応募できます皆さん是非
そして思ってみてくださいプラグ600なるのか動画概要欄館できますみなさん
ダウンロードして遊んでみてください
難しいところハズレだと思うんですけども
これからもみんなで一部盛り上げていきましょういやー
[音楽]
me
ni
バッハ